throughout history there are those
events that unfold in a way that make a
mark on a nation
on humanity the kinds of things that you
always remember where you were when they
happened
so before we talk about this finale i
just want to give a shout out to this
guy
because in this alternate timeline he's
going to spend the rest of his fictional
life
thinking of the fact that he was in the
bomb shelter
hey guys pete here this is my for all
mankind
season 2 ending explain video i'm going
to talk about the finale which was a
barn burner
just a quick spoiler warning if you
haven't watched the entirety of season 2
including the final episode then this
video won't be for you
hit the subscribe button so you won't
get lost on your way back go watch the
episode
then come right back here because
there's a lot to talk about
with that out of the way let's get right
into it the season two finale was titled
the gray
this is a callback to what karen was
saying to ed when they had their fight
in the previous episode
and we'll see that that exchange plays a
role in his decision making
before everything is said and done the
setup is complicated there is a ton of
stuff going on and i think one of the
underappreciated things about this
finale was this
opening exchange about how all that's
going on between reagan doing something
and panama doing something and then the
soviets responding
how that was all just examples of
posturing that you can pretty much tune
out by this point
until that same tech at the console
notices that
jamestown base is showing a
depressurization event
we know that this is directly related to
what happened at the end of the last
episode with the cosmonauts shooting out
the window
and we'll learn that they've taken rossi
hostage they have control of ops-com
meaning no one on earth knows what's
happening there and they came there to
recover the cosmonaut who was trying to
defect
tracy and gordo are still isolated from
the rest of the base
the defector tells the other astronauts
including the marines that the
cosmonauts won't leave without him and
this
prompts them to put together a plan to
try to make them leave
in houston at johnson space center jsc
they have no idea what's really going on
at jamestown
they're watching apollo and soyuz which
still haven't docked
on top of being in the dark about what's
happening at jamestown
margo and her staff aren't being briefed
on pathfinder and
brawn because it's a classified
operation as far as that's concerned
things aren't going according to plan
there though pathfinder is escorting sea
dragon
but ed's thinking about what happened
with karen they eventually make lunar
orbit
and that puts them in direct conflict
with the soviet blockade at first
they're surprised when they get there
that they don't encounter buron
until they find out that it's on the
other side of the moon where they can't
track it
so there's kind of a mystery of what
it's doing since jsc doesn't know what's
going on on jamestown neither does
pathfinder
and you have to give it to him this is
an impressive setup
to build incredible tension to get a
clearer picture of what it all means
what the stakes are
we listen into president reagan talking
on the phone to the soviet premier on
dropoff
the president says that they don't
recognize the blockade
and on dropoff counters that it's
actually a quarantine for offensive
weapons
he lays it out pretty clearly the
americans were the first to shoot a gun
on the moon
they're the first to kill someone on the
moon and now the soviets are drawing the
line they're not going to let them put
missiles on the moon they moved their
northern fleet into position
and it now has 30 targets in the
southern us
and reagan tells him look we get all
these missiles in western europe
which makes it a mass casualty situation
if the us destroys baron there will be a
counter-strike on earth
and the world is officially on the brink
of nuclear war
things escalate at jamestown base and we
see the marines get into suits
with a plan to breach ops-com and take
it back
tracy watches as they pass by as gordo's
trying to reconnect the cable for the
calm system
and she witnesses the shootout that
takes place where two of the marines get
shot
her friend vance is killed helena
webster
arrives and she's able to shoot one of
the soviets as he's going down
he fires off a bunch of bullets which
will turn out to be important later
because at jsc we learn that the nuclear
reactor's primary cooling pump is shut
down
and this second alert is where things
start to break down they realize that
they're not getting a response from
rossi
margo goes to tell ellen in bradford and
learns that the backup loop won't work
it was beyond her security clearance to
know about it but they brought a second
reactor to the moon to produce
weapons-grade plutonium essentially they
already did what the soviets are worried
that they're doing right now with sea
dragon
bradford says because of national
security they had to bring it online
without hooking it up to the backup loop
and now there's no failsafe
luckily elena goes to get a bag of
doritos out of the vending machine and
she hears a noise
it turns out to be gordo broadcasting on
that old
system she rushes back to mission
command to tell margo
and the reality is they have about 45
minutes
until the reactor is gonna melt down and
gordo and tracy don't have any suits
gordo says he thinks he can cover the 25
meters before he passes out
and asks them to help him make as close
to a suit as he can
so we see here the setup is complete
with gordo's storyline he's come full
circle he's in a place where he's
prepared to do what he has to do to try
to save the situation
and on some level he understands that
he'll be sacrificing himself
either way now they know what's
happening so ellen is able to contact
pathfinder to tell them about the
takeover and here
ed interprets this as the soviets
attacking because they sensed weakness
he thinks they want the moon for
themselves he sees this
in the same way that he saw things when
he was in korea
he's only able to see it in this binary
black and white kind of situation
and to make things worse bronn is hiding
behind the moon
hoping to catch pathfinder while they're
out of communication with houston
and they cross the line as they're
talking so the last thing they hear
is to protect sea dragon at all costs
the dod is now out of communication with
pathfinder
at jsc they're laying out a plan for
gordo to save
jamestown and across the country air
raid sirens start to go off
the threat level is now at defcon 2 and
there are credible threats that maybe 10
nukes are aimed at the southern u.s
and ready to go margot gives everyone a
chance to enter the bomb shelter and
just that one guy i was talking about at
the beginning goes
and the plan now is to just cancel
apollo's soyuz
when dana gets the message she's pissed
and she decides to call
soyuz she uses that connection that she
has with their
conversation about laika and throws it
out there that they need to do this
anyway
we hear molly tell gordo what he's going
to have to do and it sounds grim
doesn't sound like there's any real
chance he's got to wrap himself in duct
tape he has to put up with that melting
in the 200 degree heat
and he'll have to blow out all the air
in his lungs before he goes into the
vacuum so they don't explode
even if everything else goes right he's
only got 15 seconds until he will go
unconscious
and as he's looking at the roles of tape
tracy lets him know that she's coming
along
she makes it plain it's suicide for him
to do it alone
and he understands this so when she
makes her case he can't really disagree
pathfinder gets a message from brawn a
warning that if they don't turn around
and have sea dragon return to earth
they're gonna blow it out of the sky
there's only five minutes until sea
dragon will be in their missile range
and ed orders piscotty to open the
payload doors
to get them ready to engage with baran
at the same time bill tries to contact
the apollo team to tell him that they're
ready for re-entry
and they get the response negative
houston danny's not gonna follow the
order she's gonna proceed with the
docking procedure
and in a turn ellen backs her up saying
that she speaks for the president in
this room
and that she thinks that one good thing
should happen today
so the handshake is on and there's a
nice moment where bill gives elena the
headset so that she can give the order
so as we're watching apollo and soyuz
getting ready to dock
the soviets are leaving ops com they're
entering the base going after the
defector
pathfinder is ready to fire and gordo
and tracy are covering themselves with
duct tape
before they go out they have a goodbye
he tells her i love you trace
and she responds i love you too gordo
then they pop the airlock open and rush
out the door
where immediately the conditions of the
vacuum hit them
the music queue kinda gives away the
game this isn't the type of heroic
endeavor where they just have to be
strong and persevere
they are able to get to the cables in
the switch but we see that there's blood
spurting out of the gaps in between the
tape by the time they get to where
they're going they're covered in it
she flips the switch after he changes
the cable and the reactor starts to
stabilize and we see them start to fall
they're stumbling on their way back and
their vision's getting
blurry and we hear molly say it's taking
too long
it looks like they're not going to make
it but they do actually
work together to make it through the
door and as they're doing that we see
danny pop through the hatch in apollo
she has a great reunion with the
cosmonaut he says it's nice to see you
again friend
she responds the pleasure's all mine and
as their handshake is being broadcast
worldwide on tv
jsc is celebrating but we see that it's
playing to tvs and
empty rooms everyone's sheltering
because of the air raid
it really underlines the severity of the
situation and how
important it was that they decided to go
forward with this that they made this
decision
and that nasa did back them up president
reagan sees the broadcast on air force
one and calls helen
she starts to apologize for letting it
happen but it turns out that he loved it
because he thought it was inspirational
he thinks there may still be a way to
get out of this situation
and asks about pathfinder and boron but
they're still out of communication range
there baron tells pathfinder they have
two minutes to comply with the blockade
and that's not something that they can
do according to their mission
we get an idea of the strategy they get
a radar lock on baron
from there the plan is to wait for them
to missile lock sea dragon
and then in the mere seconds they have
fire their missiles at the soviet
shuttle as i said earlier the stakes
here are that if they do that
on earth the soviets will launch a
nuclear attack on the southern us
then the u.s will fire their missiles
from western europe
attacking the soviet union and that'll
be that
so here's the thing the setup has it so
that ed is angry he can't make sense out
of what's going on in his marriage
and here he feels like there is a clear
right answer
he needs to follow orders he needs to
complete his mission
as we're watching this it isn't even 100
clear if he understands the chain
reaction of events that are gonna happen
if he does that sally ride does see this
though
and she points out that ed's the
commander of this mission he has the
final say
this is a call back to what happened
with apollo 10.
she brings up his testifying about this
in front of congress
and when he tells her to lock their
weapon system on boron she refuses the
order
he leaves his seat to relieve her from
her post and he's going to do it himself
until she pulls her gun and puts it to
his head
and orders him to step away from the
console and you couldn't ask for a more
tense situation
piscotty tries to talk them down he
throws out the idea that maybe there's a
way that they can not
let buron shoot down sea dragon but also
not shoot them down either but we're in
a ticking clock situation and they get
the alert that barron has target lock's
sea dragon
in an instant edd fires the missiles but
we learn that he's aimed them at sea
dragon instead of buron
and thus makes the only move that he had
available to him to try to
avert the crisis there's this amazing
shot where the two shuttles pass by each
other and they make eye contact
and the look on everyone's faces show
how close they came to starting world
war 3.
it's so perfect because the soviets
don't even really know what happened
they know they had their orders
i'm sure they went through hell they
were in their own intense situation
about whether they should follow through
with their orders or not
and all anyone knows at the end is
things would have turned out a lot
differently
if they were the ones who had fired on
sea dragon
pathfinder clears the moon and they're
contacted by houston
allen asks if they shot down barron and
everyone is relieved to find out they
didn't
ed doesn't know what to make of it he
doesn't know what to think because he
did just shoot down sea dragon he was
about to tell them that
but he has no idea what happened while
they were out of contact
it turns out that reagan diverted air
force one to moscow after signing a
treaty
to pull back forces on earth and in
space within dropoff
he says he was inspired by the images of
the apollo soyuz mission
and that was enough for him to reach out
his hand in peace
on tv we see they're speculating that
andropov was willing to do that because
sea dragon was no longer a threat
it's funny because they're reporting
that sea dragon was lost due to
technical failure
and so no one will even know the real
story about what happened between baron
and pathfinder
how close things were to coming to an
end from there we see the aftermath
there are several shots of the different
characters hearing the news
and all the people at jsc realizing how
important their
work and their decision to let things go
ahead with apollo's soyuz was
we also see the soviet cosmonauts
leaving jamestown they've been given the
order to pull back
and we get one last glare from them at
their defecting comrade as they go then
in an absolutely heart-wrenching twist
rossi and some of the other astronauts
discover the bodies of tracy and gordo
they made it back to the base but they
didn't survive they died together in an
embrace
which is quite beautiful it's a sad
ending but one that's set up and it was
earned
and they were able to save everyone on
the moon
from there we jump ahead to broadcast
footage of their public funeral on tv
the old tv footage look is a really nice
touch it makes it seem like something
historical that actually happened
we see all the different members of the
cast in attendance paying their respects
there's another private moment at their
graves where ed breaks down looking at
gordo's casket
dany's there to comfort him in a nice
call back to their time together on
apollo 22
karen puts flowers on tracy's casket and
is completely devastated
their kids look broken up and it's the
kind of scene that works really well to
invoke their journey through the first
two seasons
without relying on any flashbacks just
these little shots in this intimate
moment in a private time of mourning do
a great justice to these two characters
and their story
as they get ready to go home we see that
there's still tension between ed and
karen
it's on the back burner at this point
with everything else that's happening
and through kelly's reading of her
application to the naval academy where
she talks about how this
one thing that happened her being on the
crashed first flight of operation baby
lift which is a real thing that happened
in our timeline
how that shaped the story of her life
she talks about the idea of always
thinking that things happen for a reason
and while all of this will likely be
important for her character going
forward
she says am i doing what i'm supposed to
be doing falling in my father's
footsteps
it also works really well to tie up the
season
and drive home what they were trying to
do the question that the show asked is
what if what if things happened a little
differently what would that look like
just as kelly wonders what would have
happened if she wouldn't have been on
that flight
the show is based off this idea of what
if sergey korolev
lived what if he was able to fix the
problems that the soviets were having
with their rockets
and what if they were able to put a man
on the moon first
we see the ripple effects in this
timeline from that happening
we see the changes in technology we see
the changes in
competition to try to do the next thing
in space
and in season two we saw the darker side
the conflict that comes with that
she ends her story with a great quote
from john lennon saying
everything will be okay in the end if
it's not okay
it's not the end and it turns out that
her story was not the end of the season
because we see margot get a call from
sergey as she's walking through the
graveyard he pays his respects for gordo
and tracy
saying that they were heroes for america
and the soviet union
and the whole world and that is true in
their mission apollo soyuz
with dany's decision to reach out to the
cosmonauts and go through with it
anyways played a big part
in what happened as well that's not the
only thing he calls for though and
long story short he asked her if she's
going to this conference in the uk
over the summer saying that he's going
to be there and he makes it sound like
he wants to see her personally
ask her if they can meet for a drink and
she interprets it that way
and she's taken back somewhat but she
tells him she'll have to see what she
can do
which is basically wild enthusiasm for
the margot character if you really think
about it
plus you can see that her face
reluctantly lights up after they hang up
but then we see that he's being directed
to make the call by soviet intelligence
and yeah they say she already opened the
door with baran
and that it'll be too late when she
realizes she's working for them so
there's your twist
and you know it has been mentioned and
we see it here again when he's on the
phone he wears a wedding band
and he is loyal to his country but i
still tend to think that the chemistry
they had together was real
and we'll just have to wait to see if
this is something that happened after
the fact that he got pulled in
or if it was a ruse all along after they
talk we see her go to jfk's grave
and then the camera shifts to an
overhead shot to zoom out and give us
our closing sequence it takes us on a
trip through space
the camera flies by the moon and heads
to mars where it descends to the surface
we see that it's 1995. and an
astronaut walks into frame there's boots
on the ground
and we are going to mars the question is
is that a nasa astronaut or a cosmonaut
maybe there's a joint mission going on
together or maybe this is an entirely
different thing
with the public sector getting involved
and putting people in space as well
but either way the dream of sending a
man to explore mars does seem to have
become a reality that we'll
explore in season three and it brings up
a lot of questions for example will we
start out where they're already on mars
or is this something that'll happen
midway through the season
and so what i'll do is i'll follow this
video up with my next for all mankind
video
i'll make that a season 3 questions and
prediction video so we can talk about
all this stuff
because there's a lot there so overall
an
absolutely impressive finale definitely
one of the most intense viewing
experiences from recent memory
just a ton of payoffs of things they set
up earlier in the season
and honestly some of the things that
seemed like strange decisions
make a lot more sense in retrospect now
knowing where they were headed
the thing i like about the ending is
that idea of what if something was a
little bit different obviously the main
point is what if the soviets would have
made it to the moon first
but then you can go back and look at all
these individual characters and think
about the different things that happened
to put them where they were in this
finale what if apollo 22 didn't get
trapped
on the moon what if gordo didn't lose it
what if danny didn't break her arm to
protect him
what if she wouldn't have gone to see
clayton's sister and then pushed ed to
give her command of a mission
what if ed didn't push gordo to go back
what if thomas payne didn't die on
kal-007
and that didn't inspire margot and ellen
to try to get apollo soyuz to happen
and what if karen didn't have an affair
and ed didn't find out about it right
before he got on pathfinder
i'll admit that i had a knee-jerk kind
of cynical reaction to this idea that
a handshake in space was going to change
the politicians minds
but really on reflection if you think
about it the way things are set up
they're looking for a way out of course
they're gonna say that they were
inspired
when really they were looking for a way
out and this gave it to them
ed's shooting down sea dragon was their
point where they could de-escalate but
they still needed a reason to say that
they were doing it
and i'm sure this will play really well
across the board for everybody involved
so
it was really kind of clever when you
think about it so wow this video is way
too long there's a lot more to say but
let's do that in the comments let me
know what you thought about the finale
you thought about ed living in the gray
making that decision
everyone else how they played a part and
let me know what questions you have
going into season three because like i
said i will follow up with that video
next
so that we can talk about where we think
things are going please like this video
if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already thanks for watching i'll
talk to you soon